but he loves me nobody loves you late -
about me
[Music]
that's why I care so little about myself
[Music]
and this is why you do drugs do you
think they said hi a little bit a little
bit less melancholy takes away the pain
takes a pain
Thomas Thomas a mistrial
yeah or under myself how do you drugs
they do drugs
[Music]
so your name is Tracy
Chiti pardon Trixie T Parton and you're
from Biloxi
l-look how old do you look I'm guessing
yes litleo younger cuz I have a hard
life 4045 Laurie forty you're 40 where
you still beautiful you have a beautiful
face thank you so you're all dressed up
this morning are you coming from
something react partying last night or
you're going to market I'm sorry and
party first you're not
oh that's Nate you won't wear a meeting
yeah
how long you've been going to meetings
oh my oh my and you're living on the
street 17 years
do you blame alcohol for that no I think
that from a man who took me in love I
said her husband kicked me alone you
printed up to her big trick speak about
Sierra for 17 years and you haven't
gotten over that
no being one daughter with twins you
have a daughter and where does your
daughter she lost child
I mean don't fight her foster family no
I think you get turning a dirty drug
test dirty tes tested dirty to me times
to go in from the
one of the craziest he's one of the best
things best right does that have to be
crazy no just tell me something
interesting about the nice thing a
skywalk is fella he you know I spoke
croc this fella came along
maybe others contain I said whatever you
say that they just feed you my friend
all right
that's a friend so you're doing any
drugs cocaine hello French peasant
you're a French peasant and you have one
child anywhere do you leave where do you
sleep
do you have an apartment the hotel okay
you're on the street I students cheer
biplanes come one that's almost two to
you for your pinpoints sad what I'm
tired it's his job and it gets cold in
the winter no yeah oh so close
I'm a terminator no idea and people
leave you alone you don't get it a cost
of being a single woman on the street
don't carry a gun I'm sorry I mean right
Patti oh and you can get a gun here on
the street
yeah no don't keep the trouble away and
where do you eat you don't eat sorry
Alan you only eat semen and you charge
for that or you do that for free what do
you charge for that five enough and how
many times a day to you
oh you know I ain't paying you back
during the day and you come right you
suck [ __ ] all night so proud of you
Trixie thank you very much for talking
to me welcome letting me photograph you
you're beautiful thank you I hope you
hope you stay safe out there
Hey